لذلك ساعدنا على فهم نوع
التوجه الأساسي لمصر، لأن الناس بشكل عام
يميلون إلى النظر إلى
مصر كدولة كانت إلى حد ما
جزءًا من احتواء
حماس، وكانت تفرض الحصار
بطرق مختلفة على مدى السنوات الـ 16 الماضية،
ولم تفعل ذلك.  لا تدع أه الفلسطينيين في أه كيف
كان رد فعلهم على هذا الهجوم
هجوم حماس شكرا سؤال عظيم
شكرا على أه إطلاق سراحي ديس من
الجيد أن أكون معكم رغم
الظروف الكارثية جدا فانظروا
رد الفعل المصري على ما حدث في
السابع من أكتوبر واضح جدًا، لقد كانوا
يدعون منذ اليوم الأول
لوقف إطلاق النار، أنت تعرف إحدى
المشاكل التي أعتقدها وأعتقد أن نيك نيك كريستوف
ذكر هذا في الجزء السابق الخاص بك
وهو أننا تجاوزنا نوعًا ما
أهوال أكتوبر  7 أم أن المصريين
تجاوزوا أهوال 7 أكتوبر على
الفور تقريبًا لأنهم شعروا
أنهم يستطيعون رؤية ما كان ينزل على
الرمح وهو عملية انتقامية واسعة النطاق
من قبل حكومة نتنياهو في
غزة والتي من شأنها أن تؤدي إلى
أزمة إنسانية ذات أبعاد لا تصدق
وذاك  من شأنه أن يضع مصر تحت قدر كبير
من الضغط، لذا كانت مصر منذ
البداية تدعو إلى وقف
إطلاق النار، وقد دعوا إلى
ضبط النفس الذي عقدوه، تذكر
مؤتمر السلام في أكتوبر الذي لم يسفر عن
أي شيء ولكنه كان
دليلاً واضحًا على ما  كانت
النوايا المصرية هي أن المصريين اليوم
يحاولون التفاوض مع
القطريين وحماس للتوصل إلى وقف لإطلاق النار
مقابل إطلاق سراح بعض
الرهائن، لكن هناك الكثير من الأشخاص
الذين يعتقدون أن الحكومة المصرية تميل
إلى لعب لعبة الدعم العام ولكن
بشكل خاص  إنهم يريدون نوعًا ما أن تقوم إسرائيل
بتدمير حماس، وأعتقد أنه إذا تمكن الإسرائيليون من
اختراع سلاح
يستهدف أعضاء حماس فقط ويترك
سكان غزة والبنية التحتية
لغزة سليمة، فأنا متأكد من أن المصريين
سيوقعون على ذلك ولكن المصريين يعرفون
لا يوجد شيء من هذا القبيل، وإذا نظرت
إلى السلوك المصري، وإذا نظرت إلى
تصريحاتهم العامة، فهم
يقولون للإسرائيليين باستمرار كن حذرًا
وتوقف، إذا نظرت إلى تصريحات
وزارة الخارجية المصرية، إذا
نظرت حتى إلى البيانات.  من أه
الرئيس ديسي لقد كانوا يدعون
إلى ضبط النفس وأعتقد أنهم
يدعون إليه أه علانية
ويدعون إليه خلف أه خلف
الأبواب المغلقة لكن CC معروف على سبيل المثال
أنه صارم جدًا كما تعلم إصدارات
حماس  في مصر الإخوان المسلمون
على سبيل المثال أعني أن عشرات الآلاف من
أعضائها مسجونون هل يفعل ذلك
لأن الرأي العام في مصر مؤيد
بقوة للغاية الآن للفلسطينيين
الرأي العام في مصر مؤيد
للفلسطينيين للغاية لكن الحكومة المصرية
لم تأت من  المريخ حق
الحكومة المصرية تخرج من
الشعب المصري وتقريبا بدون استثناء
يشعر المسؤولون المصريون بقدر كبير من
التعاطف مع غازين ويشعرون أن
الانتقام الإسرائيلي ضد غزة كان ناجحا
وفقا لبعض
الروايات، حيث كان هناك المزيد من المدنيين الذين
قتلوا في غزة في الماضي  تعلمون أنه منذ 6
أسابيع قُتل مدنيون أوكرانيون
منذ فبراير أه 2022، لذا فهذه
أزمة إنسانية كارثية،
فلماذا لا تسمح الحكومة المصرية
للفلسطينيين أه بالدخول إلى مصر
لسببين إذا قرأت
التصريحات العامة للرئيس سيسي التي قالها  اه جزئيا
أن السماح بدخول أه مصر سوف
يزعزع استقرار مصر لأنه فجأة الآن
سيكون لديك ملايين من الناس أه
ملايين من الغازين في شبه جزيرة سيناء
قد يكون عدد لا يحصى منهم من
مقاتلي حماس الذين سيستخدمون مصر بعد ذلك
ربما كنقطة انطلاق ل
عملياتهم ضد أه إسرائيل ثم
فجأة مصر التي منذ أه أه
معاهدة السلام مع إسرائيل كانت جزءا
من الحل في المنطقة سيتم
جرها مرة أخرى إلى مسرح الحرب
وتكون جزءا من المشكلة لذلك CCE
قلقة للغاية بشأن ذلك  والشيء الآخر الذي
يثير قلقه والذي
قاله علنًا وكل
مسؤول مصري تتحدث معه سيقوله
علنًا هو أنهم لا يريدون أن يكونوا
طرفًا في تهجير
الفلسطينيين من غزة لأنهم
يعتقدون أنه بمجرد طرد الفلسطينيين
لن تسمح لهم حكومة نتنياهو بالعودة أبدًا، ولذلك هناك
مخاوف لا أعرف ما إذا كانوا يتمتعون
بالمصداقية أم لا، لكنهم يشعرون بشدة
بأن مصر لا تريد أن تكون جزءًا
مما يمكن تسميته بـ NECA ثانية
التهجير الثاني للفلسطينيين من
أراضيهم أخيرا وبسرعة أم ما بعد
الصراع هناك كل هذه أه
المناقشات حول قوة عربية
حكومة عربية أه بعض
السلطة الفلسطينية ما رأيك أن يحدث
بعد الصراع أعتقد أن هذا
سؤال صعب للغاية أعتقد أن هناك
زوجين  من الأشياء التي تبدو لي أن بعض
المقترحات التي تم تقديمها تبدو
وكأنها أحلام كاذبة، ففكرة
أن مصر والمملكة العربية السعودية الخ ستأتيان
وتحكمان غزة بطريقة أو بأخرى أه أه
بدلاً من أم كما تعلم هاس أو بدلاً
من إسرائيل تبدو غير واقعية
يواجه المصريون صعوبة في
حكم أنفسهم، وأعتقد
أيضًا أنه لا يوجد ما يكفي من الاهتمام مرة أخرى
للتكلفة التي تتحملها مصر بسبب التورط في
مثل هذا الشيء، كما تعلمون ما هو ذلك الخط الذي
قاله ميك عن فرنسا إذا عطست فرنسا،
أصيبت أوروبا بالبرد إذا عطست مصر
الشرق الأوسط  الشرق يصاب بالسرطان، وبالتالي فإن
فكرة وضع مصر في هذا
الموقف الذي يمكن أن يكون
مزعزعًا جدًا لاستقرار البلاد أعتقد أنها
فكرة يجب أن تعطينا وقفة حقيقية،
فالقضية في غزة الآن ستتوقف بمجرد
ترويض حماس أه، القضية هي
إنشاء الحكم لا أعرف كيف
نفعل ذلك، أعرف كيف لا نفعل ذلك، وذلك
عن طريق جعل البلدان الفقيرة الضعيفة جدًا التي تمر
بأزمات مثل
مصر تحاول تحمل هذا العبء. من دواعي سروري
دائمًا أن أشكركم على ذلك.